[MUSIC PLAYING]
SCOTT ELLIS: This is SCC110.
We're going to talk about
how to discover and protect
sensitive data
virtually anywhere.
And thank you for
joining us today.
And let's just go
ahead and get started.
My name is Scott Ellis.
I'm a product manager on our
cloud security and privacy
team.
And what we're
going to cover today
is we're going to give a
quick intro about protecting
sensitive data, kind of
what sensitive data is,
and just some basic principles
around protecting it.
And then we're going
to get a little bit
of an overview of
some tools that we're
going to use, and then go into
a scenario and some live demos
of actually kind of
solving some scenarios,
and applying our tools
to solve these problems.
And we're going to show
you some of these demos
and kind of give
you an overview.
And then we also
have some samples
and how to guides
and stuff we'll
give you a link to for you
to run this yourselves.
So to get started, when we
talk about sensitive data,
the security and privacy
of the sensitive data
is a top priority.
We take it very seriously at
Google and at Google Cloud.
But we hear it
from our customers
as well that it's just a big
concern knowing what it is,
knowing where it is, and
managing it properly.
And when we think about
protecting sensitive data,
just to kind of
highlight the main goals
that you're looking for here,
is really fundamentally using
that data properly.
You might refer to this as
something like lease privilege
or need to know,
which is how do I
get this, the minimum
amount of data
that I need to do a
particular business process?
And also is this a
good business process?
Is this something
I should be doing?
Just making sure you're
kind of managing that data.
And that's a good
policy to have.
But the second
goal is really how
do you be accountable for that?
In other words,
you have a policy.
How do I actually demonstrate
that the company is following
this policy, we have
checks and balances,
we have tools in place, we
have reports and monitoring
we can generate to show
that we're accountable?
And again, demonstrate
that proper use.
And maybe it's monitoring,
maybe it's auditing.
And it's also plans in place
to kind of remediate things.
And as you're doing
that, you want
to maintain that strong
governance as your business
grows, as your data grows.
And do that with a minimal
hindrance to your employees,
to your development,
to your business,
and your service to users.
So those are kind
of the primary goals
and some kind of underlying
ways we want to do it.
When we think about insuring
this kind of data protection
or kind of governance
across data,
you have to think about
the whole data lifecycle.
And just at a high
level, that's really
where you're collecting data,
where you're storing it,
where you're
processing this data,
maybe you're using for
analytics or sharing it
with other people.
And I'm going to
highlight one thing here
is you also want
to address areas
where you might be inadvertently
collecting sensitive data.
Something where you don't
expect it to be there,
but it still shows up.
And that's something that
still you have to look out for.
And we're going to highlight an
example of that in our demos.
And what we're going
to do is we're going
to walk through a scenario.
So imagine you're a company.
You manage a lot
of customer orders,
you've got customer transactions
and customer support
that you provide.
And your goal is
you want to build
some sort of new analytics or
some machine learning model
to provide really
good customer support.
And we're going to kind
of walk through a scenario
of this company, and we
want to kind of accomplish
three main things today.
The first is can I
do a scan to discover
an audit kind of where my
sensitive data is in our cloud
project?
Then we're going to look at
how we can apply some real time
redaction to kind of remediate
some unexpected sensitive data
that we've collected.
And lastly, we're going to
kind of deep dive and look
at de-identification
and risk analysis,
really looking at
data, and preparing
it to share with an internal
team or an external team who
might be doing some analytics,
or as a partner providing
some additional
insights to your data.
We're going to kind of walk
through these scenarios
and show this kind of an action.
But before we do that,
what we want to do
is cover some of
the tools that we're
going to talk about today.
So one of the primary tools
we're going to talk about
is the Cloud Data Loss
Prevention, or DLP API.
That's one of the primary
things we're going to cover.
We'll go in a little
bit more depth.
But other tools that we're
going to mention some of you
may be familiar with,
some of you may not be.
So let's kind of get
a quick overview here.
So we're going to
talk a little bit
about Google Cloud
Storage, sometimes called
GCS, which is a--
sorry about that.
Oh, you switched
back to the slides?
Talking about Google
Cloud Storage,
which is kind of an
enterprise object storage.
We're going to talk a little
bit about BigQuery, which
is a fully managed
data warehouse and kind
of analytics system
for any scale
really, but small
to large scale.
Kind of under Workflow
Manager, we're
going to talk about a tool
called Data Flow, which
is a kind of stream in
batch processing workflow
that you can do a lot of
transformations or ETL type
workloads on.
And we're going to
use a visualization
tool called Cloud Data Studio.
So all of these tools
are available for you.
We're going to just
reference them.
And so we just want to
give a quick overview.
But let's dive a
little bit deeper
on Cloud Data Loss Prevention.
So this is a suite of tools
that really helps you control
and take charge of your data.
We've built it for cloud and
kind of hybrid use cases.
It's primarily offered through
G Suite as well as our Cloud
platform.
We're not going to cover a lot
of the G Suite stuff today,
but this is really
something that
is a tool to help
protect and discover
and protect sensitive
data in applications
like Gmail and Drive.
We're going to focus
a little bit more
on the API today,
which really allows
you to protect sensitive data
on Google Cloud Platform.
And because it has
some streaming methods,
you can really apply
it to data anywhere.
And we're going to show a
couple of examples of that.
So the main
capabilities of our API,
we've kind of broke it down
into three groups here.
The first one is really
discovery and classification
of data.
The second one is to perform
different types of what we call
de-identification transforms.
This is things like
simple redaction, masking,
and more advanced things like
format preserving encryption,
tokenization, [? suit ?]
[? automization, ?] and things
like that.
And the third is what we
call re-identification risk
analysis.
This is some additional
tools to look at your data
and do some statistical
analysis of it
to understand if it
has additional risk
of re-identification.
And we're going to
cover some of the tools
like k-anonymity and l-diversity
and some other things
that it does.
Today, we're going to
focus on k-anonymity
and show an example
of how to apply that.
So when we talk about
discovery and classification,
what we mean is
effectively looking at data
that you don't know
what's in there,
applying some of our
built in classifiers.
We have over 90 of them today.
And this includes things
like personally identifiable
information, PII like
names, location, dates.
We have global
types that kind of
apply anywhere,
credit card numbers,
as well as some country
specific identifiers.
You can also define your own.
So this, again, is maybe you
have an internal customer
ID, a patient medical
record number,
something that's not really
well-defined in the industry.
You can define
that yourself using
a custom dictionary, a
custom pattern based things
like Regex.
And we've also enhanced that
with some custom detection
rules that allow you to
apply some kind of boosting
or looking at the context
around the finding.
But again, the
whole main purpose
here is looking at data you
don't know what's in there
and trying to come out with kind
of discovering and classifying
sensitive bits that are there.
When we talk about
de-identification--
and we have a little animation
showing some examples here--
we're really talking about kind
of easy to use transformations,
handling both structured
and unstructured data.
What we're showing
in this animation
is we've got three columns of
data, or four columns of data,
three of which are structured.
You can imagine just sort
of the first, second,
and third column has an
identifier, has a job title,
has a phone number.
And we're applying some
different techniques
to mask those.
On the job title, we're doing
a kind of generalization.
And then the last
one it's a little bit
of a different column.
It's a comment field.
We can't really apply
a transformation
to that whole column other
than maybe redaction.
So what we really
have to do there
is apply a combination of that
discovery and classification
to look for the
things we care about
and then apply some
sort transformation.
So if you see here with the
email address or the phone
number, we're actually hunting
inside the comment field
and then applying a
transformation there.
And we also can do this on text
files-- again, kind of a blob
of text, if you will,
or a tabular structure,
as well as on images.
When we talk about
re-identification risk
analysis-- that kind
of third category--
I'll just show an example here
that might kind explain it,
and then we're going to go
in a little bit more in depth
and kind of show it in use.
Imagine you have this
table where you've
stripped out user ID,
you've stripped out
what's commonly known
kind of types of PII.
But you're left with something
like job title and just
some metric that
you want to protect.
Your don't want people to know
who that metric's associated
with effectively.
Well, if you look at
this table, job title's
generally pretty
not too sensitive.
But what we're really
looking at here
is there's kind of a
distribution of job titles.
Even in just these
five records, we
have four software engineers,
and we have one CEO of Google.
And it's a very unique
one in our data set,
but also anyone who sees
that job title is probably
going to know who that is.
And they've now learned what
their metric is if this was
published alongside other data.
And so really, when we
talk about something
like k-anonymity or some of
these re-identification risk
analysis tools, we're trying to
look at some of these high risk
outliers, identify them,
and then figure out
how to deal with them.
And we'll show a little
bit more of that later.
So when we think of
applying these tools,
we're really thinking of how
do we gain more intelligence
about your sensitive data?
Again, maybe you have a lot
of data in a cloud project.
Applying our API, the DLP API
to basically scan that data,
highlight where you
have sensitive data,
do some additional
analytics, you
can write the findings
directly to BigQuery,
and run a lot of
analytics in BigQuery,
or visualize something like
an audit report in something
like Data Studio.
And we're going to walk
through this in a demo
and show you how to
build an audit report.
The other thing, again, you'd
use is to do things like
to de-identify this data--
maybe it's structured data
or unstructured data--
to go in and apply some sort of
remediation or risk reduction.
Great.
So now we're going to
go, and we're going
to kind of show this in action.
Just as a reminder though, this
is what we're going to cover.
We have kind of this scenario,
we're going to go through,
and we're going to
basically create
a scan to try to discover
where our sensitive data exists
in our cloud project.
We're then going to go through
and do a real time redaction,
and kind of apply how
you might remediate
some unexpected
collection with that,
and then dive a little bit
deeper into de-identification
and risk analysis,
and show how that
can be applied in kind
of a practical scenario
to a real data set.
And again, we're going
to try to provide as many
of these samples as we can.
There's a link at the end--
kind of a short link
you can look at that
will have samples
or links to our
how to guides that
are already published
just so you can try to
recreate some of these things
if you want to.
Great.
So the first thing
we're going to look at
is we're going to,
again, create a scan
to discover where our sensitive
data exists in our project.
We think this is
important to start
with because before you
can properly handle data,
you have to know where it is.
And whether you're looking
at it at the project level,
maybe the bucket
level, or the data
set level, or the table
level, to set access control--
or you're looking at
it all the way down
at the actual content
in the string level
where you're trying to find a
string of text inside of a data
set that you want to redact--
all that begins with
knowing where it is.
And so what we're
going to do today
is we're going to use a
DLP API to discover data
in our cloud storage.
We have this bucket
that we've created
on the right side that's sort
of a company wide bucket.
We've got data from
different departments that's
thrown in there; finance,
legal, marketing,
some production
of research data.
And our goal is we want to
produce an audit report.
Basically do a scan of this
data, print out what you found,
where you found it, and
see if there's any issues.
And very specifically,
we want to make
sure that we're not storing or
writing raw credit card numbers
anywhere on our infrastructure.
And we've also-- in
some of these folders,
we've got small files.
And in some cases, we've
got some big files in here.
So this is just a screenshot of
sort of the Production folder
where there's a kind of a
relatively large [? CSV ?]
files being exported in here.
So we want to also take
that into consideration
both speed, efficiency,
and cost efficiency
of how we run the scan.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to effectively initiate
a scan using the G Cloud
integration with DLP.
So what G Cloud is is it's a
command line interface that you
can use to kind of interact
with a lot of Cloud products,
whether you're copying a
file or accessing something--
let's say BigQuery--
it's really a simple
command line interface
you can use that
doesn't require coding.
It just run a command
and see it happen.
We're going to use
our DLP integration
with that to accomplish this.
We're going to tell
that command to save
the findings in BigQuery.
And then we're going to use Data
Studio to visualize an audit
report and show you what
that could look like.
Great.
So let's switch
over to the demo.
Do you want to switch
over to demo 1?
And what we're
going to do here is
we're going initiate
that command in G Cloud.
So we're first just going
to open the Cloud Shell.
And again, we're going
to kind of walk through
all the steps here.
This is running in Cloud
Shell, which is a simple way
to get a command prompt just by
logging into our cloud console.
You could obviously
run this on your own VM
or your own local machine if
you have G Cloud installed.
And so first what
we're going to do
is we're going to
list out all the jobs.
So we're going to look at a
relatively simple command that
just says, hey, to DLP, go
list all the jobs that I
have for this project.
And as you see, we've
created a couple of jobs
here, very simple jobs
looking for a couple of things
that are going to look for.
And then we're going
to actually-- let's
create a new job.
And I'll talk through this
command for one second.
Again, it's a relatively
simple command line,
but still pretty powerful.
What we're specifying
here is we're going
to scan our cloud storage.
We put in a what's called a URL
or URI for the cloud storage
bucket.
We've specified that
we want to write
the output to our
BigQuery table that we
manage, which in this case,
is in a certain data set.
And the table's
called Results 1.
We said we're going to look
for phone number, email
address, credit card
number, and something
called GCP credentials,
which I'll explain
in a little bit what that is.
And we're going to do a
very fast limited scan.
We didn't want to scan
everything exhaustively.
We just want to do a kind
of a very fast limit scan.
So go ahead and
run this command.
So by issuing this command,
it's going to respond back
with a hey, I created the job.
Here's some details about it.
So if you go ahead and go back
and do the list jobs command,
we'll see now that we should
have a third job showing up
there that's currently running.
So again, it's that simple.
Just create a command like that,
and you're already scanning
an entire cloud storage bucket.
Next, we're going to
jump over to Data Studio.
We've created a little
relatively simple audit report.
And what we've done here
with this audit report
is we basically just created
a couple of charts and graphs.
But fundamentally,
what we're doing is
we're reading from that BigQuery
table that the DLP creates.
It basically takes all that
scanning and the findings
and creates a
structured database.
And then we've just
shown that here.
So in this left side
here, we're showing
kind of a simple listing of
the files and count of what
was found there.
On the right side,
again, we looked
for four different types.
And we just show a count
of the four different types
that we found.
Phone number and email
was the most prevalent.
We've got a little
bit of a warning.
It might be hard to see, but
that kind of red pink credit
cards up there is a highlight
that we found something
of that particular type.
And let's go ahead drill down.
We're going to limit it
to just one of the jobs
that we ran here.
And then we'll drill
down once it loads,
and look at just credit cards.
So we're limiting it to
just one of the jobs here.
And what this does
is we basically
said now just show us the files
that have credit card numbers.
And we see that we
have one file here
that looks like a copy
of our chat transcripts.
It looks like there was some raw
credit card numbers in there,
and so that's something
we're going investigate next.
But before we do that, let's
go and jump over and just look
at another type,
the GCP credentials.
So this isn't
necessarily a type of PII
or personally
identifiable information.
What this is it's a detector
for the kind of GCP service
accounts.
So if you create
a service account,
save it as a JSON file to use.
This looks like somebody created
one of these service accounts
and uploaded it to one of
our cloud storage buckets.
And that may be of a concern.
If a lot of people
have access to that,
and that has access to your
resources, your data, that's
something you want
to be aware of.
And so you want to make sure
that that is properly protected
or removed from cloud storage.
So that's just another
example of things
that the API can look for.
Great.
So I think let's jump
back to the slides.
And we walk through the
G Cloud command here.
And again-- so what
do we look for.
If we accomplish our goal,
we create an audit report.
This report looks like we
found several files that
have PII, one of which contained
raw credit card numbers, which
is something we really wanted
to make sure we didn't have.
And we also found what looks
like maybe a production GCP
service account
kind of JSON file.
Now, before we move
on to the next step,
we want to dive a little
deeper on the technical details
of what the API would
have looked like.
So again, we used
a G Cloud command.
But let's look at
what that API call
might have looked like if you
were to just do a direct API
call.
Or if you're using
a particular client
library or a different language,
kind of more of the details
here.
So what we're showing here
is a JSON representation
of the REST API call.
And what we're doing here
is if you kind of remember
from the G Cloud
command, we're going
to go through what that API
call would kind of look like.
So first, we would specify
where we want to scan.
In this case, it's the
cloud storage bucket.
Maybe we're going to put some
limits and sampling on it.
So pick some settings
on how to do that.
Specify what to look for.
I put a couple of different
types in here just
to show the different
ones we have.
But essentially, you just
put the name of the type,
and that's going to trigger
our detector to run.
So in this case, credit card
number, Social Security number,
and a few others.
And then what action you want
to take after the job is done.
In this case, we just
want to write it out--
write out detailed
findings into BigQuery.
So that's a simple API call.
Again, you can do all that
in the G Cloud as well.
So next, we're going
to look at kind
of how do we remediate that
chat file that we found?
Or what caused that?
How could we prevent it
from happening again?
We're going to try to
apply some real time
redaction to remediate this.
So if we dive into one of
these chat transcripts--
I just put a sample of it here--
what we see is that
it looks like there's
information in there that
we didn't need to collect.
And so we're going to try
to figure out what that is
and how we might remediate it.
In some cases, you might call
that data minimisation, kind
of a term of make
sure you're only
collecting the minimum
amount of data that you need.
And in this case,
it wasn't intended
to collect this information.
But we definitely didn't need
it, and we did collect it.
So what we're going to look at
here is in the chat session,
as you see, the agent
asked for the last four
digits of a Social.
And the customer
gave the full Social.
Later on, he said
something about a card,
and it looks like we got
a full credit card number.
So these are things
we didn't want.
And we really didn't
want the agent
to see it in the first place.
And we definitely don't want to
save it, persist it, and have
to manage that data.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to feed these chat
messages into our content
methods of our API, which is
kind of a streaming real time
method.
And we're going to de-identify
them by masking or redacting
the information that we
don't need and produce
sort of a cleaner chat message.
And that's what we're
going to show to the agent,
and that's what we're going
to persist in our system.
So let's go ahead and
switch over to demo 1 again.
And we're just going to
load an application here
that we've kind of
created to show this.
And what we've created here is
a simple App Engine application.
This particular one
is written in Go.
We'll send a link to some of the
Go code at the end of the talk.
And what we're showing
here is on the left side,
we've got a box where
we can type things in.
And on the right
side, we're going
to show what that would look
like after it's been processed
by our API in real time.
So let's go ahead and
load the sample chat.
And what we see here on the left
is as that kind of information
is typed in, on the
right side is how
we're applying a policy here.
And in this case, we've
decided to apply a policy that
will mask everything
but the last four digits
of Social Security numbers,
and fully redact other things
like credit card numbers.
So something that simple--
again, as you're typing,
we can apply that policy.
And you have full control over
what the policy looks like,
what you look for,
and things like that.
And-- Good.
I think-- let's switch
back over to the slides.
Great.
So that's kind of
applying it in real time.
So you imagine you could build
that directly into your chat
support app, feedback app,
things like that that might
be collecting data
where you don't
expect it to have this certain
sensitive data in there.
And like we did
before, let's just dive
a little into the details
of what that might
look like on the API side.
So again, we're going to
look at an API call here.
And in this case, we're
not scanning cloud storage.
So we didn't give
it a bucket to scan.
But instead, we actually
streamed the data in.
So here's an example of just
streaming a string of text in.
We've asked it to look for
Social Security numbers
and apply a masking transform.
And then for other things like
credit card number, just simply
redact.
So again this is
showing a little bit
of what that transformer
de-identification
policy might look like or
the de-identification config.
And we applied this to
something that we built just
as a little simple app--
like an App Engine example.
But if you think about
it, it's in real time.
So as you have data
in other systems,
or you have third
party data that
has APIs where you
can use this data,
you can also build this
into other systems.
So we've played around in
this a little bit and built--
like in this example,
we built a Slack bot
that we kind of
went in and said,
hey, let's see if we can
use the APIs from Slack,
build a simple Slack bot, stream
that data through our API.
And we set up this
demo chat room,
and we kind of put some
information in there
and then ran a command
and said, what's there?
So in this case, you can see you
can build it in a third party
so you can kind of use
it on data virtually
anywhere, whether it's a real
time case like this, or data
that you just manage this
off GCP or in some system
that you control.
And next, we're going
to dive a little deeper
into de-identification
and risk analysis.
And my colleague here,
Michael, is going
to go and present that for you.
And here you go, Michael.
MICHAEL DAUB: [CLEARS THROAT]
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks, Scott.
So my name is Michael Daub.
I'm a software engineer
working on cloud DLP.
And so for the second
half of the demo,
I'm going to talk about some
of the more advanced features
that we offer with the
DLP API, specifically
de-identification
and risk analysis
of large structured data.
So recall in the
last demo, Scott
showed you how to
de-identify these chat
messages in real time to make
sure the agent doesn't see it
and that we're
not persisting it.
But you might imagine
that we've already
collected these messages,
and we haven't performed
de-identification yet.
We're already storing
them in BigQuery,
and we need to go back and
make sure we eliminate any PII
that we don't actually need.
Alternatively, you can
imagine a situation
where there is sensitive
data that serves
a legitimate business purpose.
But some internal
team needs access
to the data for analysis,
but they don't need access
to the sensitive data.
And so in either
of these cases, we
need to take this data
that lives in BigQuery,
de-identify it just like
in the previous demo,
and then write it back to
BigQuery so a copy of it
can be shared with the analysts.
So it's going to look
very similar to what
we did before, except
the data, instead
of originating in
the chat app, is
going to originate in BigQuery.
Then we're going to
send it to the DLP
API for de-identification and
then write it back to BigQuery,
and do the exact same
transformations we did before.
Except this time, instead
of doing it in real time,
we're going to do it in batch.
And so we're going to use
Cloud Data Flow to orchestrate
the workflow that reads
the data from BigQuery,
calls the DLP API, and then
writes it back to BigQuery.
And so we're going to use some
open source code that Google
published to GitHub.
Again, at the end
of the session,
we'll provide you with a
link to the GitHub project
so that you can run the code
on your own BigQuery table
if you like.
And so right now, we're not
going to run Data Flow live.
We're going to do
that in a moment.
So we're just going to
skip over to the results.
And so if you take a
look, the top section
is the data before we
actually applied DID,
and the bottom is after.
And so first, I'm going to call
your attention to the User ID
field.
So in the top, before
we de-identified it,
it's just the
sequential user ID,
which is the raw
user ID that we don't
want to share with the analysts
because they might have access
to some other data source that
then they could join on this
using the user ID column.
And so we don't want
them to have that.
But we might want
to at a later time,
take any analysis they've
done and figure out
who the person is.
So instead of just
redacting it, we're
going to use format
preserving encryption
where we're going to
apply cryptography
using a private
key that can then
be used later to reverse it.
And in the output, it just
looks like some random number.
But it's actually encrypted
and can be reversed.
And then in the
chat messages, we're
going to scan for, in this
case, the customer service agent
names, as well as Social
Security numbers and some
of the other PII and
then just replace
them with the type
of PII that was found
so that the analysts will know
what type of PII is missing,
but not the actual
sensitive contents.
And so the technical details,
It's the exact same API request
that Scott showed before.
I'm just going to
highlight some other--
call your attention to
some other parts of it.
Just like before,
we are going to list
some built in system
defined info types that
are available to everybody.
But you can imagine
that you can't expect--
you wouldn't expect
the DLP API to know
about specific
types that are only
going to exist in your
data set because they're
specific to your business.
For example, the custom
case number, in this case,
is just going to be two
uppercase letters followed
by six digits.
So using our custom
Regex detector,
you can actually
define your own type.
And then for the
custom agent name,
we just provide a list
of all the customer
service agents that are
employed by the company
in a dictionary that lives in
a file in Google Cloud Storage.
And then if you
just provide that,
the API will look
up the dictionary
and then search for those
custom agent names in the data.
And then in terms of the
de-identification config--
so for the user
ID, here we've just
defined the format
preserving encryption
with the provided key to
encrypt those user IDs,
and then redact everything
else, replace it
with the name of the info type.
So now suppose that you're not
sharing with an internal team.
You actually need to share it
with some external marketing
firm to perform
further analysis.
In this case, we need to take
a bit more care because we're
sharing it with a team that
might be a little less trusted
than an internal team.
And so we've already
taken the obvious steps
of redacting what are called
direct identifiers, things that
will always obviously
identify a user like user ID,
social security
number, and so forth.
But since we want to
take a bit more care,
what else do we
have to worry about?
So there's this concept
called quasi identifiers,
which are identifiers that may
not directly identify somebody.
If you recall the example Scott
gave earlier of job title,
for the most part, job
title won't directly
identify somebody.
But CEO of Google
certainly would.
In this case, we're
actually going
to look at zip code and age.
Which any particular zip
code and any particular age,
there are probably going
to be multiple people
in your data set for a
given zip code or age.
But actually, quasi
identifiers can be identifying
when taken together.
A specific combination
of zip code and age
might uniquely identify a user
just because the zip code might
have a low population,
and the age
might be a demographic with
very low population as well.
And so in this sample
data set, observe
that there might be five
people of this zip code,
maybe there are more
that we're not showing.
But there could be one
person who's age is 81,
and that person would
be highly identifying.
And so we want to make
sure that we're not
sharing this with
the marketing firm
because they might have access
to public data sets that
contain these
demographic features,
or they might have their
own internal data sets.
And we want to stop them
from joining any other data
sets on this one, or doing
any other kind of thing that
would expose the
user's personal data.
So first of all, how do we
deal with these outliers,
and also how do we
measure the risk?
So one thing we could
do is we could just
remove all these outliers.
Just going back to this
previous side for a sec.
We could drop all these
unique combinations
of zip code and age.
But there could
be only two people
or three people with a given
set of quasi identifiers.
And that's still risky,
even though they're not
uniquely identifiable.
So to talk about
this kind of risk,
we're going to use a
concept of k-anonymity.
Which if you're
not familiar with,
don't worry about it too much.
It's quite simple.
It's just how many
people share the same set
of quasi identifiers--
age and zip code
in our case-- in
a given data set.
And so for every possible
combination of age and zip
code, we're going to count
of the number of people.
And that's what k-anonymity is.
And in our case, we're going to
target a policy of k equals 10.
This could vary from
use case to use case
depending on who
you're sharing with it,
and what your assumptions
about the attacker might be,
and how much risk
you can tolerate.
But for the purposes
of this demo,
we're going to aim
for k equals 10.
And so we're going
to do is we're
going to take the data
which lives in BigQuery,
and we're going to call the DLP
API, the risk analysis method,
to compute k-anonymity.
Then we're going to
take the output, put it
in Google Data Studio to
visualize the results.
So if we can switch
back over to the demo.
OK.
So as you can see,
Scott has pulled up
the Google API
Explorer, which allows
you to make API calls to
various Google Cloud Services.
And so here, he has a request up
for the DLP risk analysis API.
It's fairly simple.
So we're just defining the
quasi identifiers we care about.
In this case, it's
age and zip code.
And then below, we just
specify the source table,
which is our chats to table.
And then, again, we're
going to specify an action,
we want to save the results so
we can generate the histogram,
and we're going to
save it to this table
live risk for r1 or x1.
SCOTT ELLIS: x1.
MICHAEL DAUB: And then we're
going to give it a unique job
ID so we can figure out which
job corresponds to the results,
and then hit execute.
And hopefully, it worked.
Yep.
And so on a larger data
set, it might take longer.
But this is a test data set,
so it's probably already done.
It only takes seconds.
So we're going to switch
over to Google Data Studio
and open up this report we made.
And don't worry about how
we generate this report.
There's a detailed how to guide
that we're going to provide
at the end of the talk.
But for now, before looking
too much at the graph,
let's talk about what these
axes mean and sort of figure
out what this graph means.
So the x-axis, which
is labeled k-anonymity,
is just, as we talked
about, the number of users
for each set of values
of quasi identifiers.
But in this case, we've
aggregated it together
into a histogram.
So at the far left, k
equals 1, we've just
taken everybody who
lives in a zip code--
a particular age that's
uniquely identifying,
and aggregated them into
one bucket, and said,
the blue line is
the number of rows--
or the percentage of total rows
that correspond to k equals 1.
And the red is the percentage
of unique zip and age
combinations.
And so the results
don't look very good,
because just for k equals
1, already 10% of the data
is k equals 1 and
27% of the values.
And it quickly jumps
up to the point
where once we reach k
equals 9, 100% of our data
is lost both in terms
of the number of rows
and the number of distinct
age, zip code combinations.
So this isn't good.
We can't just by removing
all of these outliers
achieve our goal of k equals 10
without losing all of our data.
And so can we switch
back to the slides?
So how do we fix this?
It seems like we're in
an impossible situation
because we can't remove
the risky outliers,
but we also need
some data to analyze.
And so the solution is
to use generalization
using the (DLP) API.
So generalization is a
technique for, instead
of just completely
dropping data,
we're going to replace it with
a value that's not as specific.
So for example, we might take
ages in a particular range,
and instead of
outputting the exact age,
we're going to output
buckets of ages.
So we might take all
numbers between 20 and 30
and just output 30, all numbers
30 and 40 and output 40,
and so forth.
And if we do this,
it will reduce
the granularity of the
data and reduce the risk.
And so now, what
we're going to do
for this final
part of the demo is
we're going to
combine the last two
steps where we used Data Flow
to perform de-identification.
This time, we're going to do
the exact same thing as we
did before, but
we're going to add
this bucketing transformation
we didn't do the first time.
And we're going to bucket
the ages to make it
a little bit less identifying.
Then we're going to perform the
second step, take the output,
pipe it into DLP's
risk analysis API,
and then once again see
how the results compare
to the first de-identified--
or the data that did not
have the bucketing performed.
And so switch back to the demo.
And so now we're
going to actually show
the running of the Data Flow
pipeline, which Scott's just
going to SSH into a virtual
machine which we've installed
this GitHub library on.
And the GitHub page has
all the instructions
on how to run this,
so don't worry too
much about the exact command.
But Scott's just
going to prepare it
by exporting the credentials so
that we're authenticated when
we actually call Data Flow.
And so now we're going to run
this command, which, again,
don't worry too much about it.
But we're specifying
the input table chats2.
We're specifying
the output table
which Scott has called
live_deid_chats2_bucket10_x2.
And then the
configuration, which
is the same configuration we
used before, except it has
the bucketing transformation.
And so the data
set's pretty small.
So when Scott runs it, it should
finish probably within seconds.
For a larger data set, it
might take a bit more time.
But for this test data
set, it's done pretty fast.
And so now we're
going to switch over
to BigQuery real quick
just to look at the output.
And so first, Scott's
going to pull up the data
set chats2, which was the
original data set that
has not yet been de-identified.
And if we look at it, ages now--
18, 19, 20, 21, so forth--
have not been bucketed.
We've just for the purpose of
this demo dropped the chats,
but normally, we might
keep the chats in there.
But just to speed up the
de-identification and Data
Flow, we remove that.
And so now if we go
to the output table,
it's all the same columns,
except now we've applied DID.
And looking at the
output, now you
see there are no ages except
for exact multiples of 10
because we bucketed
them all up together.
And so now, we're going
to quickly go back
to the API Explorer and rerun
risk analysis on this output
data set.
And so Scott's just going to
copy the table name that we
just wrote the output to.
And the API request is
going to be exactly the same
because we're running
the same metric.
The only difference
is we want to run it
on a different output table, the
newly de-identified data set.
And then we're going to write it
to a slightly different output
table, and we're also going
to use a different job
ID because we already
used live risk before X1.
We're just going to call
it live risk after x1.
And hopefully this will work.
All right.
Good.
So now, if we switch
back to Data Studio,
we're going to take the exact
same chart we prepared before.
But we're just going to
change the data source
to the new table that we wrote
the output of risk analysis to.
So if-- Scott's just going
to click Edit and then
change the data source from the
original data set to the one
we just created.
And once that's done, the
graph will be updated.
And we're going to see what
the results of applying
this bucketing was on the risk.
So it's disappearing now.
But if you recall, it
started out relatively high,
and then quickly
jumped up in terms
of the amount of
data loss experienced
by removing the outliers.
But this looks much
better already,
because if you look at k
equals 1, it's kind of hidden,
but it says 0.3%.
Only 0.3% of all rows
correspond to k equals 1
after applying this bucketing.
And only 5% of the values are
lost if we want to k equals 1.
And it increases
very slowly up to k
equals 8, the data
loss, and only starts
jumping up when we
hit k equals 15.
And we can get actually
all the way up to k
equals 40 before we
lose all of our data.
But since our goal was k
equals 10, this was a success.
We can hit k equals 10 and
only lose about 4% of the rows
and about 20% of
our distinct values.
So switch back to the slides.
So I'm just going to skip over
that, because we already showed
you the graph that was back up.
So let's just look at the
technical details real quick.
We use the exact same DID to
config we showed you earlier,
only we added this
extra bucketing config
for applying the bucketing
transformation to the age
column.
And it's actually a
very flexible API.
We just say what the min value
and the max value of the range
for the bucketing is.
And in this case, we defined
the replacement value
to be the upper end
of the range 30.
But you could define it
to be whatever you want.
You could make it a string that
is just 20-30, sort of gives
a range.
You could choose
the lower endpoint
20, the midpoint 25, the
upper end 30, or pretty much
whatever you want.
And so quick summary of what
we just showed you is first,
Scott showed you how to scan
your Google Cloud Storage
bucket for sensitive data
and generate an audit report.
Then he showed you how to
in real time de-identify
the chat messages so that
analysts didn't have to see PII
and so that we weren't storing
the sensitive data we didn't
need.
And then we showed
you in the second half
how to de-identify a data
set using Data Flow and share
with an internal team,
and then use risk analysis
to make sure it's safe for
sharing with an external team.
[MUSIC PLAYING]